So the speed of light is a constant. But
the important thing about variables in Python is that
they can vary. That's why they're called variables. Once
we define the variable, we can change the value.
And then when we use that name again it
refers to the new value. So let's see that
in an interpreter. We could change the value of
cycles_per_second. Suppose we have a faster processor. Now we've upgraded,
we've got a 2.8 Ghz processor. Now, that doesn't
affect the value of cycle distance. This was already computed
with the old cycles_per_second. We still get the result, 0.111.
We'll compute it again. This time the value of cycles
per second is the new value since we changed
what cycles per second refers to. And now when we
print cycle_distance we see that the values changed. So we
have a faster processor the second time we print cycle_distance
now we only have 0.107 meters, less than 0.11
centimeters per cycle. So what happens now that we
have assignment, the same expression can have different meanings
at different times we evaluate it. The value of the
speed of light divided by cycles per second depends
on what the current value of cycles per second is.
When we evaluate the first one, the value was
2 billion 700 million, so we got a different result,
which was the 0.111 result we got the first time.
When we evaluate the same expression the second time, the
result's different, because the value that cycles_per_second refers to is
different. And that's why we get the smaller cycle_distance the
second time. So, let's see what's going on there and
make sure we understand assignment. So, suppose we have a
variable, days. And we'll initialize it to the value 7
times 7. So what that does is introduce a name days.
And it refers to a value, which is the result
of that expression. So it refers to the value 49, and
that means when we look at the name days, we
see what it refers to and we get the result, 49.
If we do another assignment. Let's say we have one
less day. And in this case we'll assign 48 to days.
Well, that's a new assignment. We already have a name days.
It used to refer to 49. But after the new assignment,
it's going to refer to this new value. Now
it's going to refer to the value 48. The
number 49 still exists, but days no longer refers
to it. Now days refers to 48. Where things
get more interesting is we can use variables in
their own assignment statements. So here we have an
assignment statement where we have the value days minus
1 and we assign that to days. So what
happens with that assignment? Well, we evaluate the right
side first. We look for the value of days
and we see that it refers to 48. We
compute days minus 1 and we get the value 47.
Then we do the assignment that will assign to
the variable days. So now the value days refers to
the value 47, no longer refers to 48. So
we could keep doing that, if we did another statement,
same exact one, that's going to change the value again.
This time, the first time, the value days is 47,
we'll subtract 1, we'll get the value 46. And then
we do the assignment, that'll change the value, so now
days refers to the value 46. So the important thing
to notice, this is not an equal symbol. This looks
like an equal symbol. If you studied algebra you would
think an equation like this looks like an equality, and
there is no way to solve an equation like that.
In Python and in most programming language, equal does not mean
equal. What equal means is assignment. You should really think of
it as an arrow. It's an arrow saying put whatever value
of the right side evaluates to, into the name on the
left side. We don't write it as an arrow in most
programming languages. There's some that do, just because an arrow is
harder to type, and lots of programs have lots of assignments.
But you should think of the equal
sign as not meaning equal, it means assignment.